NICK BUTCHER: All right.
Hello, and welcome to
today's Android
Developers Office Hours.
My name is Nick Butcher, and I'm
joined here in London by--
MATT GAUNT: Matt.
CHRIS BANES: And Chris Banes.
NICK BUTCHER: Regulars Rich
Hyndman and Stephan at
Droidcon Berlin today.
So unless the Wi-Fi conference
gods are smiling on them, I
don't think they're going
to be joining us.
So as usual, this is your chance
to come and ask us, the
Android Developer Relations
team, any questions about
developing Android apps.
It's not an opportunity to ask
us about unreleased features
and products and stuff like that
and road-mapping needs,
because we're not going to be
able to share that kind of
information, unfortunately.
So without further ado, it seems
that we have a couple of
people joining us live.
We have Yossi over there.
Yossi?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Hi, guys.
NICK BUTCHER: And Stephen
Charman I can see.
And who's that who just
joined as well?
Oh, everyone's joining.
Hi, everyone.
While everyone joins, should we
start off by taking a quick
look at some of the questions
that have been pre-submitted
into the moderator, and then
we can come back to that?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah,
let's go for it.
So Hugo Visser from the
Netherlands has asked, is
there a supported way
to change the
locale within your app?
He's found a way on
Stack Overflows.
There's a couple of
people [INAUDIBLE]
had to do it who have a hack by
changing the configuration.
And honestly, I don't know
the answer to it.
I'd guess it's a hack and it
shouldn't really be done.
You've got to ask yourself
why you want to do this.
NICK BUTCHER: I'm curious and
that going to be my follow-up.
Why would you do that?
[INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS BANES: Exactly.
It's a system setting.
They set it once.
It's their language.
What is the need for your app
to change their locale?
So it sounds like you can do it,
but it's a hack and it may
not work in the future.
NICK BUTCHER: So I guess
the answer is no.
We don't think there is a
supported way of doing it.
CHRIS BANES: Not supported.
NICK BUTCHER: Not--
Yeah, exactly.
Cool.
Should we ask the--
YOSSI ELKRIEF: But why not
suggest to the user to choose
the language he wants to see the
menus for the application?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, one thing
he could probably do is
probably deep link them to the
screen in Settings where they
can change it.
So rather than automatically
changing it, he might be able
to link them through.
But I don't know about
automatically changing it.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, it's
a [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Whether you want
to be able to or not.
CHRIS BANES: It sounds like it's
a question of, if you've
got a user and you haven't
localized your app--
[INAUDIBLE]
[? NICK BUTCHER: ?]
Cheers, Yossi.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Thanks.
CHRIS BANES: Has anyone in the
Hangout got a question?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, I've
got one or two maybe.
CHRIS BANES: Or two.
Or three.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
No, no.
First one, it's not really
related to Android, but I'm
trying to see if there is
a Google Groups API.
Do you know anything about it?
NICK BUTCHER: Nope.
CHRIS BANES: No.
NICK BUTCHER: Sorry.
Not my department.
CHRIS BANES: I thought you could
access Google Groups via
NNTP as like a standard
news group.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: OK, I'll
check it out.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, because
that's how it was
born, wasn't it?
It was like a web interface
to news groups.
And then it just kind of grew
into its own net product.
So I'm sure they've still got
some binding somewhere.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: OK.
I'll do some searching.
Thanks.
CHRIS BANES: All right.
Stephen's asked a question
with the sidebar.
Can you un-mute and ask it
yourself or without video.
NICK BUTCHER: It's on mute.
CHRIS BANES: No mic.
OK.
MALE SPEAKER: I have
a question also.
Can you hear me?
CHRIS BANES: OK, you go for
it, and we'll come back to
you, Stephen.
Yes, we can hear you.
MALE SPEAKER: Hello.
Hi, everyone.
I also added the question
to the moderator area.
It's about the action view
intent and the possibility to
add multiple URIs for images
in order for the gallery to
act as in a slide show mode.
Is this possible some way?
CHRIS BANES: No.
MALE SPEAKER: Ah, OK.
So I need to implement something
by myself in order
to provide such an action.
OK, thanks.
CHRIS BANES: There are a number
of libraries, open
source libraries that you can
use for this kind of thing.
And they make it really easy.
So have a Google.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, thanks.
NICK BUTCHER: Should we give
it up to Stephen's?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
So in the sidebar Stephen asks,
is it good practice to
open a connection to the
database and then hold onto it
for the lifetime of
the application?
The trouble you have with that
is you'll never know when to
close the database, because
there is not a sort of
[? undestroy ?]
application.
So you're going to keep holding
onto the database
connection and it's never
going to be closed.
So you shouldn't be holding
resources in your database.
If you try and open that data
if your app gets killed, the
database won't be closed.
So the next time you try and
open it, you'll get an
exception saying, database
isn't closed or something
isn't right.
It's a nice, easy option
to get around sort of
[? handling ?] databases.
I wouldn't recommend
it, personally.
NICK BUTCHER: What would
you recommend?
CHRIS BANES: I don't know.
The more I sort of play with
databases, the more content
providers just seem
the best way.
There are a lot of boiler
plate we have to write.
NICK BUTCHER: There's a ton of
good libraries that will help
you write all that for
you like Storm
and other such things.
So I think content provider is
probably the way to go there,
and have that handle your
database connection.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, I agree.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, you get a
lot of stuff for free if you
want to use loaders
and what not.
Then you need to be using
this architecture.
OK, cool, that was
my impression.
Cool.
Good.
Glad we could confirm that.
Any other live questions
before we jump
back into the moderator?
There is one guy whose avatar
is him with his hand up.
And I keep on thinking he's
trying to ask a question.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
CHRIS BANES: --but
that's just me.
NICK BUTCHER: What's the
best way to access
fragments by tag?
Oh, by tag?
Question mark, I'm guessing.
CHRIS BANES: Find fragments
by tag as a method?
NICK BUTCHER: Are you asking
like the best way to keep hold
of them, like to get
hold of them?
Then yeah, tag is
a very good way.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Great.
Makes a great video watching
us read a sidebar with a
conversation going on.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
For view pages.
MATT GAUNT: Oh, so if you're
using fragments within a view
page, yeah.
Why would you need to get
them via tag, though?
Because couldn't you just pull
them out of the adapter.
CHRIS BANES: No, because
it's a view, isn't it?
Because view pager only
deals with views.
You've got fragment pager
adapter, which sort of handles
all the fragment [INAUDIBLE]
side of it.
So yeah.
The way you've put it
in is a good way.
Sort of creating a custom tag
based on the position is the
way I've done it in the past.
So much like you've done.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh,
[? by pinning ?] the position.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
CHRIS BANES: Or you just create
custom sort of object,
lots of strings that all
go to each fragment.
Is this using a hidden feature?
Is it not?
NICK BUTCHER: Sort of.
Yes, it's
implementation-specific, isn't it?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
Anyway, that's the way
I've done it in
the past and it works.
I can't really think of a
better way of doing it.
Just go for it.
You got a questions
in the moderator?
My tablet seized up.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, OK.
So go back into the moderator.
When are you going to do this?
Not going to comment on that.
So let me find another one.
Multiple images.
So we just answered that one.
CHRIS BANES: Yup.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
So Kenny in Los Angeles says,
showAsAction="ifRoom" doesn't
work as I would expect.
Even when there's plenty
of room, these
actions aren't shown.
And it links through to a
Stack Overflow thread.
Have you had a chance
to look at that one?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
I mean, the Stack Overflow
thread, answered it pretty
well, and you've got an answer
from Jake Wharton.
So it's a pretty definitive
answer.
Basically, the action bar, sort
of the number of items
you can have as action items is
fixed based on the resource
of it, based on sort of size
of screen, what sort of
orientation you've got
the device in.
And it changes based on that.
So for instance, on a 10-inch
tablet in landscape, it's five
items you can have.
NICK BUTCHER: Or two.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, or two.
So if [? there ?]
[? isn't ?] enough room on your
items, it will sort of
wrap after five items.
But you can force your items
to display using always.
So there is that.
It's kind been done like that
for sort of consistency.
And also so the items displayed
don't change based
on what else you've got
in the action bar.
So total, subtotal, list
navigation, spinner.
And so it still has room
for those items.
And so if you hide or show any
of those, your item number
isn't going to change.
NICK BUTCHER: And I think these
are all documented on
the design guidelines.
If you get to the action bar
page on the developerandroid
.com/design/pattern/actionbar
or something like that, then
it's actually documented at
how many items are always
shown in each size screen
and orientation.
All right.
We'll actually go from the
top, any questions.
So Springy in the UK asks--
he wants to use bidirectional
NFC transceiving, like the
Google I/O example.
ICS above, Android Beam
gets in the way.
Is there any way to
work around it?
CHRIS BANES: I honestly
don't know.
Yeah, I can't answer that,
because I don't know enough
about NFCs or the
Android Beam.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PAUL: Hi there?
NICK BUTCHER: Hey, Paul.
PAUL: We've recently been
looking into this.
In fact, my boss was
at the Barcelona
Mobile World Congress.
CHRIS BANES: Oh, yeah?
PAUL: Beam does seem to be
slightly a bit of a problem
with the extra touch required.
It wasn't going down too well
with some people who weren't
familiar with NFC.
And I'm basically trying to
find the same kind of way
around this issue for doing
a kind of message sort of
challenge response, kind
of two-way process.
So at the moment, I'm not
getting any answers out of--
there doesn't seem to be any way
around this at the moment.
What was shown in the Google
I/O a few years ago was a
previous version before they
had the touch to Beam.
And it's slightly more easy to
work around, but I think it's
been tightened up since then.
But yeah, I'm in
the same boat.
I'd love to know if there's
anything else coming up or
anything else that's
been announced.
But I haven't found
anything so far.
CHRIS BANES: My suspicion
is no.
PAUL: Yeah.
I think so.
CHRIS BANES: I think Beam
is the way forward.
PAUL: Yeah.
It would be great to, for the
sort of use cases that I'm
facing and what this other
chap's facing, is to have a
mechanism for a sort of--
when you send some data and get
a response back, I'm not
sure what the best way
is for the moment.
So if there is something, it
would great to find out if
there's something like
that in the future.
NICK BUTCHER: Right.
OK.
Well, I guess that's one we're
going to have to take away.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah,
we don't know.
NICK BUTCHER: Thanks
for the feedback.
That's interesting to
hear that Beam isn't
always the way forward.
OK.
Trying to find the
next question.
Multiple image URIs, we've
done that one.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah,
MATT GAUNT: So there's the
in-app billing one.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
MATT GAUNT: So Jeremy from
Australia is just essentially
having issues with
in-app billing.
Essentially, what's happening
is his activity's being
destroyed before he's actually
receiving the billing result.
And then, yeah, Chris has
already kind of answered on
Stack Overflow.
He kind of said, use an alert
dialogue, convert that to a
DialogFragment, and try posting
a Runnable using
run-on UI thread.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
So from what I read about that,
it's not really an issue
with in-app purchase.
It's just a general sort of
Android issue where your
[INAUDIBLE]
you're showing a dialogue
while the
activity isn't being shown.
So it's just [? something's ?]
been leaked.
And sort of the in-app billing
side of it is kind of red
herring from what I read.
So yeah.
DialogFragment was added so you
don't have to lose stuff
anymore, so you don't have
to handle the life cycle.
It's all handled for you--
fragments.
And it's just the nice
way of doing it now.
Obviously there are some styling
issues in that you can
use that alert dialogue,
and it gives you a lot
of styling for free.
But often the pros of using
DialogFragment with the life
cycle is sort of--
free-ness is good.
NICK BUTCHER: And there was
a good post on the Android
Developers blog about how
to use DialogFragment.
Go to
android-developers.blogspot.com
you can find that.
Cool.
And another one is just another
Stack Overflow link.
Have a look at this one.
When to delete files shared
with external
apps by content provider.
From Martin in Slovakia.
CHRIS BANES: I'm on
the wrong page.
NICK BUTCHER: Does
it ring a bell?
CHRIS BANES: No,
I [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Let's
take a look at it.
[INAUDIBLE]
OK.
We'll come back to that.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, I'm trying.
So Efren from the Canary Islands
has asked, when are we
going to start taking
the public sort
of BugTracker seriously?
He said, there are nearly 30,000
issues that nobody
seems to care about.
Some of them affect
millions of users.
As I've said in the reply, the
tracker is checked, and it is
checked very regularly.
NICK BUTCHER: Every bug.
CHRIS BANES: It's just
there may not be
replies on each of them.
And sort of fixes are put in.
NICK BUTCHER: It's kind of the
way that Android is developed,
because Android's developed
internally at Google and then
open-sourced.
We actually maintain like a
public-- sorry, private
BugTracker as well.
So things like that,
we'll look at.
And then we might file internal
bugs and work on
those internally, and then
you won't see them,
the effects of this--
the bug report you put in--
until the next release when
that code's pushed.
So it might seem like we're
not responding.
But we do actually
read them all.
And things like adding Arabic
support was because it was the
number one starred issue
on BugTracker.
And we do look at these for
prioritization as well.
So sorry if it feels like you're
whistling in the wind,
but we do look at it.
So keep trying.
CHRIS BANES: So Jean Francois
in France asked, what's the
best solution to do a custom SSO
solution with an override
of the authenticator
class and service?
The account is linked to an
external state, which is there
for credentials.
Not quite sure what
he's asking.
NICK BUTCHER: No,
neither do I.
MATT GAUNT: I didn't get
that one either.
NICK BUTCHER: So I'm guessing
you're asking [INAUDIBLE].
So I guess you're asking for, if
you have the device hold a
credential for your service,
your sites and have multiple
apps using it, in which case,
I'd say, yeah, use Account
Manager infrastructure.
And it's definitely the way
forward to do that.
If that's not what your question
is, can you please
reply to the moderator
and clarify?
CHRIS BANES: [INAUDIBLE] page.
NICK BUTCHER: Why Android
isn't executing catch
statement code?
The exception is caught, but
it's only executing return
statement or code before
in catch is executed.
It's weird.
This is the only ORMLite--
in other cases catching
[INAUDIBLE] is working fine.
CHRIS BANES: It sounds very much
[INAUDIBLE] specific if
you mention ORMLite.
Don't know.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
I'd get in touch with a
developer of ORMLite because
that does not sound like the
general state of the world,
catch statements are executed.
Or else we'd be in
a lot of trouble.
CHRIS BANES: So Aiden in London
has asked-- is using
the Google Maps API version 2.
And the map fragment sometimes
freezes when it doesn't
respond to user input.
Is this something you're aware
of, and is there a fix?
I don't know.
Check betaandroid.com.
There may be a bug report
already on there.
MATT GAUNT: It might be a case
you're doing something on the
UI thread as well.
You're not quite thinking
[INAUDIBLE].
I guess you could easily
identify that if you just had
a button on the action
bar or something.
If you don't click on that, then
the whole UI's blocked.
CHRIS BANES: Or you
[INAUDIBLE]
and see what's going on.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, even better.
CHRIS BANES: Or maybe you're
using a live, sort of a UI
widget which sort of intersects
touch events.
Something like a sliding
library or something.
I don't know.
Which is [? inset ?] in touch
events at certain points.
And so the map fragment
doesn't get them.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Well, systrace will tell
you what's going on.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: You see
where it is going.
So Marius in Romania asks, is
it possible using Android
Asset Studio at all to preserve
the content padding
and stretch regions when
creating an eye patch?
Right now, when changing the
image, the padding and stretch
regions are reset to default.
I think that sounds
like a bug.
With Asset Studio, if it is
doing that, I don't think
that's correct behavior.
So there is actually a Report
A Bug, BugTracker section.
It's just a Google
code project.
So if you can file a bug on
that, then we'll take a look.
MATT GAUNT: You have any
questions live while we're
still going through these?
I'm looking at you, Giuseppe.
You've always got a question.
MALE SPEAKER: I just wanted to
ask you another thing about
the sliding menu.
The same feature that we have
right now on Google +
application in Android.
I'm looking for a library to do
the same effect, to achieve
the same effect.
And I found several libraries,
and I want you to guide me to
a specific one that you think
is more suitable.
One is called Sliding Menu, and
it also has support for
ActionBarSherlock.
MATT GAUNT: [INAUDIBLE]
Yeah.
I tried a load of them and
Sliding Menu seemed to be the
one that was the most active
with development.
They also fixed some stuff after
Richard Hyndman had kind
of had a look and realized that
you were actually still
painting the menu even though
it was invisible.
So they ended up fixing
that, which a lot
of the others didn't.
It seemed like the most robust
one that I played with.
So yeah.
That's what I'd go for.
But there are a handful.
MALE SPEAKER: OK, thanks.
CHRIS BANES: Cool.
NICK BUTCHER: My moderator
was turned around.
So Andrew
One-Man-Motoration-Machine
Kelly asks a long question.
If I background my app using the
Home button is there any
reason why, two seconds later,
when I relaunch the app, the
complete back stack
is not restored?
I have a front door activity
which keeps getting shown when
foregrounding, even though
[INAUDIBLE].
I think you answered this
one question already.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, this one--
we need more information.
Well, I need more information.
So I'd look for the source of
how it sort of-- your app is
actually relaunched from
the recent apps drawer.
And there's two things
that happen.
If your app is still sort of
in memory and it's still
active, it will just sort of
bring it to the front.
And if not, it will launch
intent based on various things
that will just relaunch
your app.
I'm guessing that your app is
still sort of active, so it's
doing the bring in to front.
So I had to think about
how this might happen.
And the only thing I can really
think is that you've
got activities in
different tasks.
And so you've got your activity
stack, and that's in
a separate task.
And then when it's brought
back to front, Android is
relaunching your
original task.
And so your original
activity's being
sort of shown again.
But I'm sorry, it's a
total guess from the
description you give.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
I'd say, yeah.
Flags sound like a bit of a--
it could potentially mess up
your history there.
So check [INAUDIBLE] you have
the new task flag set on the
activity, which it might be a
desired behavior for certain
situations, it's going
to do that.
That's going to be
the behavior.
MATT GAUNT: Out of interest,
what would happen if you had
don't keep activities ticked
in the developer options?
Would that kill it if you
hit the Home button?
NICK BUTCHER: Mm hmm.
MATT GAUNT: So that
would create
another thing if you've--
CHRIS BANES: Yeah,
it's [INAUDIBLE].
MATT GAUNT: Because I had that
before where it was just
killing some stuff.
And I had never really realized
why until I actually
remembered I had switched
that on.
So that might be something.
That you just left on.
CHRIS BANES: See, I'd check your
manifest and also your
intents, and just triple check
whether you're doing some
funky stuff.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
Ram in Chennai says, is it
advisable to restart a service
from onDestroy()?
And what happens to the data
storage or any storage options
when the device power
fails suddenly?
Since shared preferences use
XML file and DB uses file
system to store data, will the
file DB get corrupted?
CHRIS BANES: So for the first
question, depends on why your
activity's being destroyed.
If it's--
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
service.
CHRIS BANES: Oh, sorry.
Service, yeah.
So if it's being sort of
destroyed using memory
constraints and sort of the
Android is actively sort of
killing your service, what you
should use is you should use
Start Sticky, because that
will automatically do
all this for you.
Somewhat.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
onStart command and then return
the right value from
onStart command.
So basically, don't
fight the system.
And when it's trying to kill
you, trying to restart itself,
that sounds pretty extreme and
like really try to avoid
fighting the system.
So yeah.
More look at starting Sticky
and service, and the system
will restart you when it has
enough resources to run you.
CHRIS BANES: And if it is an
important service, you can use
startForeground, which will
mean your service is as
important as an activity,
foregrounded activity.
MATT GAUNT: And you have to
provide a notification.
CHRIS BANES: And second part.
The question was something to
do with data power loss and
[INAUDIBLE].
So there are various things
that can happen in here.
And it mostly sort of depends on
file systems, whether that
sort of file system's got
journaling, so using the XT3
or whatever.
But these are all
device-specific sort of
implementations.
And so the only surefire thing
you can do, really, is to try
and combat this, if
it ever happens.
So if you try and read a
preference and it's not there
or it's been corrupted or
whatever or the database has
been corrupted, to try
and think of ways to
sort of work around.
It.
So I don't know.
Create backups of database or
your preferences as needed.
NICK BUTCHER: If you're really
worried about it, if it's
really critical that you don't
lose it, then probably you
don't want to be using these
high-level abstractions like
shared preferences
and databases.
You probably want to be working
at the file level and
then looking at the guarantees
that the different file
systems will make to you.
And if it's super critical
information like financial
information, transaction
information you just cannot
lose, then yeah, you probably
want to get a little bit lower
level and look at the guarantees
they make.
If it's not as critical, then
you probably can rely on these
high-level abstractions.
So if you're looking at
shared preferences,
then there's two ways.
You can either apply
or commit them.
They're two different methods.
One is going to be async So
there's a slightly larger
chance of you not knowing it's
written and before it returns
control to you.
Whereas, if you do the
synchronous one, you'll know
when it returns control to
your program that's been
written, so you can guarantee
it's been persisted.
So it depends on the data and
how critical it is and how the
impact of losing any
of it will be.
But generally, not a
massive issue, I'd
say, to worry about.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, I
wouldn't say it's--
NICK BUTCHER: It's not going
to keep me up at night.
[INAUDIBLE]
Right.
I think we've exhausted
the moderator.
MATT GAUNT: [INAUDIBLE]
NICK BUTCHER: Go for it.
MATT GAUNT: If you have a
premium app with a lot of
customers who have already
paid but you want to
transition to a freemium app
using in-app purchases in the
subscriptions, will the Google
Play store properly return the
original purchase status
to the [? last ?]
API once you to declare
the app to be free?
NICK BUTCHER: Unfortunately
not.
This is a general problem of
which we don't have a great
solution of migrating pages
to a freemium model.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
I've seen some innovative
workarounds like [INAUDIBLE]
sold the freemium app.
And then in the freemium app,
you use package managers to
detect if the premium
one is installed.
Basically, it becomes
like an un-locker.
You can issue an update so it
even removes the launcher icon
but it stays installed as the
kind of un-locker app.
And then enabling the same
functionality as if they'd
done the app purchase.
So that's one possible
work-around.
But unfortunately, yeah.
As we said, the service
[INAUDIBLE] won't
return for a free app.
CHRIS BANES: So Luke in
the chat has said
we missed his question.
MATT GAUNT: Ah.
Do you want to ask it now?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Luke, what was your question?
Can you un-mute or
are you no mic?
MATT GAUNT: Also Anna Marie, I
do not understand what you're
asking us at all.
Sorry.
If you can reword it,
then maybe we'll be
able to answer it.
But you have to be quick.
NICK BUTCHER: Well, he's running
out of time here.
CHRIS BANES: So I think, is
it Luke from Australia?
I think that's the one.
So he's asked, just wondering
if there's any way to change
the default composition
arrow on map fragment?
NICK BUTCHER: No, there's not.
CHRIS BANES: Like a
car, for example.
He used to have to do
this [INAUDIBLE]
method in version 1.
But it doesn't look like
you can in version 2.
NICK BUTCHER: I don't know
the answer to that.
CHRIS BANES: I don't
think you can.
Because most of the methods
are final now,
if I remember rightly.
They've really tightened up map
fragment and all the sort
of related methods.
So yeah.
Unfortunately, it doesn't
look like you can.
NICK BUTCHER: Any other live
questions or should we wrap up
a little early?
Three minutes.
Oh, Giuseppe's hand is up.
MATT GAUNT: Who else.
NICK BUTCHER: All right.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Just [INAUDIBLE]
few minutes, OK?
What is the best approach for
an application that must
upload to a socket
[? center ?]
continuously stream?
I mean, suppose that
I [INAUDIBLE]
the byte array from
the camera.
OK?
And I would like to upload
continuously
to a dot net server.
OK?
What is the best approach
for Android [? Word? ?]
The socket system?
Another way?
What do you suggest for
continuously upload?
CHRIS BANES: In terms
of [INAUDIBLE]
it's quite a broad
topic to do this.
So it depends.
Does it need to be real time?
So does it need to be there
as fast as possible?
Or is it kind of--
MALE SPEAKER: Real time
with some delay.
CHRIS BANES: Real time
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, five
seconds, six seconds, eight
seconds is acceptable delay.
MATT GAUNT: So you essentially
want to--
so the way that I've done this
in the past was you can
essentially get access
to the camera--
so essentially take the camera's
view and stick it on
a service view.
And then you can read that and
there's a way you can convert
it to an RTP stream.
And then, essentially, stream
that and read it from the
server side.
There's a couple of open
source projects
that do this for you.
Because there's one little thing
where the header of each
packet, there is no size.
So yeah.
Basically, the RTP stream, the
way it's done is it needs to
know the packet size.
And by default, that won't get
added in, so you have to do
some chipping around with it.
But it makes a lot of sense
in terms of you're using a
standard stream protocol at
[? CDP ?] so it's going to get
there as fast as it can.
Yeah.
That's the way I've done it.
I think you were telling me
about this before, about the,
is it the end data point?
Something?
I don't know.
Look at the open source
projects, and you will see
what I mean about the
length of the
packets not being right.
That's the only caveat.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
Right.
So I think that brings us to
the end of our time today.
So thanks everyone
for joining us.
And as always, we do prefer if
you can get the questions in
ahead of time in the moderator,
so it actually
gives us a chance to research
some of this stuff and get you
a better answer.
So yeah.
Thanks everyone for joining us,
and we'll catch you same
time next week.
Bye.
MATT GAUNT: Bye, everybody.
CHRIS BANES: Cheers, guys.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Bye, guys.
Thank you.